hi in this video I will talk about
bilirubin metabolism so the precursor
for paraben metabolism is him so
bilirubin is formed from him so you must
be familiar with the term bilirubin
because bilirubin level increase during
jaundice that causes a yellow
pigmentation in the skin so we need to
talk about bilirubin metabolism first we
would look where the heme is produced so
heme is produced during enriched
replaces in the mitochondria so once him
is produced and hemoglobin is formed RBC
would be circulating all over the body
you can see RBC is circulating all over
the body but RBC have a lifespan of 120
days after 120 days when RBC's grow old
they would reach the spleen
so spleen is the graveyard of our PC so
in the spleen there are splenic
macrophages so these macrophages would
pick up those old RBC's and they would
actually degrade the RBC so inside the
RBC we have hemoglobin so hemoglobin
would be degraded into two parts one is
him another is globing so him would be
further broken down and ferrous would be
that means iron would be recycled and
used further and him would be broken
down and the other cyclic compound of
the heme would be broken down and it
would form bilirubin and globin would be
broken down and recycled so first what
happens this is the structure of heme
you can see it has four protoporphyrin
ring and these four in the center of
this four ring there is a ferrous which
is generated from the lone pairs of
nitrogen so this heme would be broken
down by the
action of the enzyme would break down
this him to form delivering so Billy
Verdun is a intermediate and after that
Bolivar ding reductase would actually
convert believer ting into Billy Rubin
and in this process NADPH is converted
into an ADP so this is a reduction step
and the reduction potential comes from
the NADPH so you can see in the Bolivar
ding and in the pillar being inside the
red box you can see more hydrogen is
added so this is this is how bilirubin
is formed this build Rubin which is
formed by reduction of believer reading
is actually unconjugated unconjugated
bilirubin is insoluble so unconjugated
bilirubin would move to the circulation
and so it as it is what water insoluble
it have to work with any carrier protein
in this condition the carrier protein
would be albumin albumin would conjugate
with it and it would carry the
unconjugated bilirubin to liver where it
would be further metabolized so in the
liver unconjugated bilirubin would be
converted into conjugated bilirubin with
the action of UDP glucose i'll
transference now I'm shook unconjugated
bilirubin was insoluble but UDP glucose
I'll transference would add a clue
Coronel Group which would make it
soluble and the soluble bilirubin would
be secreted into the intestine and
inside the intestine it would pass
through the intestine and ultimately it
would reach the large intestine so in
the large intestine further steps take
place so in the large intestine so you
can see in the bigger picture the
conjugated bilirubin is converted into
urobilinogen upon bacterial activity
then this urobilinogen
is further converted to stocker billing
and starker billing is excreted in with
the fecal matter so you can see some
amount of Europe the lineage in is
converted into star kabillion and some
amount of urobilinogen is converted is
absorbed and it moves to kidney and
inside the kidneys someone want of
urobilinogen is converted to euro
billing and euro billing gives the urine
its characteristic yellow color and the
other portion of the star coupling is
actually excreted and excreted into the
stool so that is why our fecal matter or
stool has a characteristic brown color
so this is how bilirubin is actually
eliminated from the body
if bilirubin is not eliminated properly
then there is an accumulation of
bilirubin which is common in jaundice
that is why we need to study the pillar
Ruben metabolism I hope you enjoyed the
video if you liked my give video please
like it subscribe to my channel and
don't forget to leave your comments
below thank you